hi
good afternoon everyone uh my name is
priyana trajan
i'm an astrophysicist and serve as the
current director of the frankie program
in science in the humanities at yale
i am delighted to invite you all to our
monthly
inference colloquium series uh though
first i
would like to recognize our benefactors
mr and mrs richard
and barbara frankie who are uh
on the call today and have joined us and
i also want to remind all of you
that we are recording this event and the
recording is made available
within a week or so and since we are
recording
uh we are required to have all
participants uh
mute their videos and um if you wish
uh to participate in the q a which we uh
encourage
we would like you to submit questions
through the chat feature and feel free
to submit your questions throughout
although we will handle the questions
and
the speaker will address them at the end
of their talk
so um i am absolutely delighted
today to introduce our speaker
professor james owen weatherall who is
a professor of logic and philosophy of
science at the university of california
irvine
but he's also a member of the institute
for mathematical behavioral sciences
and center for cosmology and
as you all know part of the
goal for this series is to really try to
understand
explore and understand issues related to
epistemic models
correlation causation and we could not
have uh a better
speaker than today's to provide deep
insights
into what models really do and
over his career he has looked at a range
of questions
very very interesting very topical
questions his most recent
book is titled the misinformation age
how
false beliefs spread and which is
co-authored with kailyn o'connor
in which he sort of explores the social
dynamics and the spread if you will
of belief uh in evidence-rich
environments
he has several uh previous books as well
one on the void which is the first one
of his that i actually read and
thoroughly enjoyed that was published in
2016
by yale university press his current
research interests as i mentioned
uh span a range of very very relevant
issues that have to do
with mathematical and conceptual
foundations of physics
philosophy of cosmology and social
epistemology
today uh he will be talking to us about
polarization of beliefs in particular
on issues where at the gist life facts
in contrast to opinions so one striking
feature as you have all probably noted
of the current political environment in
the united states and elsewhere
is that there are large groups of people
with extremely divergent beliefs
about what are in fact testable matters
of fact
so these are matters of fact where there
is a rich and widely accessible body of
scientific evidence
that will clearly support one side over
the other
and despite that there is a raging
dispute
and so you know we have all seen this
manifested
in the political environment um with the
elections and the aftermath of the
elections
as well as the unfolding global pandemic
and all the public health and medical
issues that have
arisen around that and we have seen in
many ways
the you know in the context of the
provisional nature of science we've sort
of seen this interplay
of the honing and refining of
facts and data and evidence and belief
formation we've all sort of had you know
front row seat to how some of these
processes occur
especially in this past year in his talk
today
jim will draw on recent modeling work to
provide
three distinct possible explanations for
this polarization in belief
and each of these explanations invokes
very different mechanisms and recommends
different remedies he will conclude with
a discussion of what it
means from the perspective of
epistemology of a model based science
that such different models can produce
such similar
outcomes and the moral of
his talk today will be to caution us
against very overly simplistic
explanations
and understand that these are issues of
great complexity
and therefore there are no silver bullet
solutions
to our current quandary sort of living
in an environment
which is rampant with misinformation
disinformation
and rampant denial of scientific facts
and i just want to mention that as per
custom
tomorrow we will host a conversation
between
professor weatherall and professor kevin
dorst of the department of philosophy
from the university of pittsburgh and at
the same time so may 26 tomorrow at 3
p.m
and so we are really really looking
forward uh jim to your talk today
um please take it away and thank you so
much to both of you for accepting
this invitation uh thank you so much
priya um and uh thank you for your work
in organizing the
the series um i've enjoyed the other
talks and i'm glad to get to participate
so i'm gonna uh share a uh
screen here
um great so uh just gonna jump right in
um uh i'm gonna talk today about
polarization
um and so let me just be clear right up
front what i mean by polarization
because there are a few different
kinds of uh phenomena that
arise in um you know in this context
that sometimes get this name
so what i have in mind when i talk about
polarization today
is a situation in which you have a
community
of epistemic agents
so by that i mean um a community
of people who are trying to
learn about how the world is
and so um polarization arises in such a
community
when the various members of the
community
come to hold beliefs
that diverge from one another uh so i'm
talking about situations where
uh agents come to uh hold divergent
beliefs about matters of fact and i want
to be very clear when i say belief i'm
not talking about
religious belief i'm not talking about
um
assertions about values what matters uh
whether something is important or not
um what i'm talking about are um
uh credences about matters of facts so
um
the the amount of confidence that you
have that some
assertion about the world is true or
false
now um polarization apparently obtains
in real world situations um
there are uh many examples just we've
seen in the last several years
for instance um you posed the question
was there widespread voter fraud if
widespread is too
fuzzy a word was there voter fraud at a
scale sufficient to influence the
outcome of
the 2020 u.s election um
considerable amounts of polling data
suggests that there really is
a divergent there really are divergent
beliefs
um in the the u.s population about that
question
um with a great deal of confidence on
both sides about what the
the facts are so this is the kind of
situation
that i have in mind and uh
um i'm focusing here as priya mentioned
in the introduction on cases where it's
not just that there are these
disagreements but in fact
there appears to be information
available to the community
that um bears on uh
uh the uh the situation in the sense
that um there should be evidence there's
evidence available
um prima facie it appears that that
evidence ought to be sufficient to
settle
the issue one way or the other and yet
nonetheless it doesn't seem as if
uh consensus emerges
okay and so what i'm going to do today
is uh
talk about three different models in
which polarization
is a possible outcome these are
agent-based models in which
i um uh will describe how
um sort of very simplified setting
idealized agents
um gather information about the world
and share that information
and then update their beliefs in light
of that information
and show that in each of these models
polarization is a possible outcome
now each of these models can be
understood
to suggest a prima facie plausible
explanation of real world polarization
these are the kinds of explanations
that you sometimes see theorized
as the explanation for actual real world
polarization
but as i'll discuss each of the models
differs
in the kind of explanation that they
offer
um and in the uh
the the details of the conditions under
which you should expect
polarization to appear
um and then so you know most of the talk
is going to
be discussing these various models and
what kinds of explanations of
polarization they suggest
but i'm going to conclude by uh thinking
about
some issues in philosophy of modeling
about what we can infer
from this situation what we can infer
from the fact that a single phenomenon
a single social phenomenon in this case
can be plausibly modeled
in such different ways
i want to acknowledge my uh collaborator
so i'm going to be discussing three
different papers two of which
have appeared in print one of which is
unpublished
um caitlin o'connor is a co-author
on all of these papers um also co-author
of the book that priya mentioned
misinformation age
where some of these results are
discussed
okay so we discussed the um the
uh modeling methodology briefly so i as
i said i'm going to discuss here
agent-based models
i want to emphasize these are highly
idealized
models these are not meant to provide
a
fully accurate um complete
representation
of any kind of human activity
they're supposed to abstract some
particular
collection of salient features that
one might ask whether so where one might
ask whether those features
are sufficient under some circumstances
to bring about some sort of qualitative
uh phenomenon um and so
um we're reasoning with highly abstract
and highly idealized models
um i'm going to describe how the models
work so hopefully you'll you'll get a
sense of how this
works but i just want to flag up front
that we aren't trying to give
uh various similitudinous
representations of um the the
actual you know social world here we're
doing something a little bit different
from that
um two of the models that i'm going to
uh discuss are within the same
uh modeling framework known as the
network epistemology framework
and then the third considers individual
bayesian learning
now each project establishes conditions
under which polarization may emerge
now i absolutely do not want to suggest
that these are
uh the only models in which this happens
or the most important models in which
this happens
or um anything like that um
they're representative in a sense uh
but i'm describing some of the models
that i've worked on um
there are many many other models some
very similar some very different from
the ones i'm going to discuss
that um lead to very similar sorts of
uh arguments and and observations
um okay good
so um i'm going to begin by giving sort
of an overview of the
the framework in which the first two
models uh
lives um the network epistemology
framework
i'm then going to um introduce two
versions to network epistemology models
that uh
um uh i'm going to discuss one based on
what i i'm going to call trust dynamics
one based on what i'm going to call
conformity then i'm going to introduce
the
the third model which works in a
somewhat different
framework and discuss how
that can be used to understand some
aspects of journalistic practices
and then i'm going to conclude with a
discussion of what we can learn
from this modeling situation
so to begin network epistemology
so to build the models in the first two
of uh
these parts of the talk we work in a
framework that was
um originally developed by two uh
economists
uh vega teshbala and uh sanjiv
um they were working with an audience of
economists in mind
uh but their work was adapted to the
philosophy of science context
uh about 15 years ago now by
kevin zollman who's the uh the one on
the far
left there and so um since then
there's been a a community of people
working in philosophy of science
using this sort of framework to try to
understand various aspects
of the social spread of evidence and
belief
within epistemic communities generally
and
specifically within scientific
communities
so the way these these models work
is that you have um a decision problem
so basically you're trying to to choose
between
two possible actions um we're going to
call one action a
the other one action b now the setup
here is that action a and action b
when they succeed provide the same
payoff
but they succeed at different rates and
so you're uncertain about which one has
a higher expected value because you're
uncertain about
which one succeeds at the higher rate
so we're going to assume here that in
fact one of these actions has been well
studied and
all of the agents are confident that
that action is uh succeeds at a rate of
of
0.5 so half the time it succeeds it
gives payoff one half the time it fails
and it gives no payoff
um but they're uncertain about the rate
at which the other action
action b succeeds and they're trying to
learn
about whether action b has a higher
expected value or a lower expected value
um by testing that right there they're
performing
the idea is that they perform uh uh
the various actions they learn based on
what happens when they do perform the
actions they update their beliefs about
which action is better
and so there's a whole community trying
to converge to
um all act in the way that yields the
higher expected value
now this is a very simple problem of
course there's certain kinds of
scientific situations
that have this qualitative feature so
for instance
you might think about a situation where
a new medication is introduced and
if that medication succeeds it has the
outcome that a patient
is survives and if it fails the the
patient does not survive
you can have two you know you're trying
to compare now is this new medication
more or less successful
than some existing medication whose
success rate
is well known um
one thing that's that's nice about this
particular kind of example is
they're pretty high stakes so you want
to perform whatever action you think is
the
the better one even though you're of
course very very interested in learning
uh from others whether or not perhaps
the other action turns out
to be better after all
okay and so um this is the problem that
our our agents are trying to solve
we represent the agents as having
credences so these credences
can be represented as a single number
between zero and one we can think of
that as the probability
that the agent each agent assigns
to the proposition that b is better
now i i should um say in all of these
models we're just adopting the
convention that in fact b
is better um this is important because
there really is a better outcome
um you know there's a fact of the matter
there's some some
truth here that we can know about
outside the model and which we can
observe now how the agents
uh learn how successfully they are at
learning about
um whether or not b is in fact better
okay and so um the agents uh
uh are arranged on a network so the idea
is that
each agent in each round of a simulation
is understood to perform an action they
perform the action that they think is
better
some number of times
um so if they're the number that
represents their credence is greater
than 0.5 they perform action b
if it's less than 0.5 they perform
action a some number of times
after doing that you can think of this
as a kind of
performing an experiment you you get
some sample
um and could be one but it could be
greater than one so you could
perform the action several times think
of that as the results of an experiment
and now
you take that data and each agent
updates
their belief in light of that data
using bayes rule okay
now in addition to updating based on
their own data
this is where the network structure
comes in right this is why this is
network epistemology
in addition to updating uh
their beliefs based on their own data
all of the agents
also update their beliefs based on the
data generated by
their immediate neighbors and so what
happens here
is that you have at least to begin with
uh different agents in the network
performing the two different actions
but then in general uh all or
or many of the agents receiving
information not only about what they
think is the better action but also
what their neighbors think is the better
action this way they can update on
on both kinds of actions and eventually
they converge to um
some sort of outcome okay now
um this basic model as i've just
described it is one in which
generally authors have found that
communities
converge towards consensus that is
either all of the agents converge
to having very high confidence that
action b is in fact better
an outcome that we'll call true
consensus so um
uh consensus about the truth
the other possibility is that the agents
all erroneously settle
on the worst action a now but because of
the structure of this model
um you're you're going to get one or the
other so basically what's going to
happen is eventually all of the agents
are going to be performing action b
which is in fact better and
overall the data is going to tend to
keep their beliefs that b is better
high or what's going to happen is that
all of them are going to come to believe
that a is better and
no one will perform action b anymore and
so you end up with a stable outcome
where no new information about action b
is gathered because everyone has decided
that the
the worse action is uh better
okay so that that's the the the basic
model that we're going to be working
with the first
two parts of this talk here um now i'm
going to
discuss the first of two modifications
to this model
that introduced some component that
might be understood to explain
polarization okay so this is based on a
paper that caitlin and i wrote
that was published in the european
journal for philosophy of science a few
years ago called scientific polarization
so in this model what we do is we begin
with the same network epistemology model
that uh i discussed but we modify
how agents update in light of evidence
produced by other agents
so agents still update in light of their
own evidence in the same way
but they update in light of uh
other agents evidence in a different way
the idea here that the motivation for
this um
is that we suppose that agents
take some evidence to be of higher
quality
than others um and
uh the higher quality evidence they're
going to take
they're going to be very confident in
lower quality evidence they're going to
be
less confident so how do they determine
what kind of evidence to be confident in
um
well of course there are various ways in
which you can imagine very complicated
high rationality sorts of strategies for
figuring this out
um here we suppose just a very simple
one
which is that um the agents take
the data generated by people who
disagree with them
to be less trustworthy
now why would you do that uh so
one idea here is that um in
if you're evaluating someone's
information the information that someone
is sharing with you
and you think okay this is an epistemic
process
they've somehow gathered this data
i'd like to try to evaluate how good
they are as epistemic ajax
how likely are they to come to good
conclusions
collect data reliably and so on um and
i'm going to
use their past epistemic success by my
own lights
to evaluate that and so the idea is that
if i look around and i see
well these people uh according to the
data that i have access to
and and the beliefs that i hold appear
to have succeeded
in their epistemic tasks i'm going to
assume that the data they're sharing
with me
is more reliable and the people who
by my own lives appear to have failed at
their epistemic tasks
i'm going to understand to likely be
producing
data that's less reliable now i'm still
going to treat
that data in general as something i
could update on
but i'm going to treat it as less
certain
so here's the idea um i
am going to um model
trust here as
a um an assignment of
uncertainty to the amount
sorry assignment of uncertainty to the
data produced
by other agents
where the amount of uncertainty
is described by some function that
decreases
with the distance between my beliefs
and the agent who's produced the data's
beliefs
and so the idea here is that an agent
who um
if someone produces evidence that is
um if someone holds beliefs that are
very distant from mine
whatever evidence they produce i'm gonna
treat that as
uh more uncertain than
uh evidence produced by someone who is
closer to my own beliefs
now um the updating rule that we use
here i i didn't write it down on the
slide but it's a standard updating rule
and alternative
to bayes rule for um updating beliefs in
light of evidence known as
jeffrey conditionalization which is the
standard way of
updating beliefs in light of uncertain
evidence
and so what's going on here is we're
treating uh evidence produced by others
as
uncertain evidence with some degree of
uncertainty
that's determined by this function
now i'll just note that this kind of
strategy
um so using jeffrey conditionalization
uh
to model this i believe is original to
this paper
but the the basic kind of strategy where
you conditionalize
how you uh how agents update
their beliefs or their opinions based on
some function of the
distance between their beliefs or
opinions
uh is widespread in the literature this
is something that's been been studied at
least since the early 2000s
um and uh and so what we're doing is
adapting
this kind of um this kind of mechanism
uh to the network epistemology framework
and introducing the idea that
jeffrey conditionalization is a
a useful way of of modeling
now i'll just note that we have to
introduce some decreasing
function uh of the distance between
agents beliefs to do this
we consider several different ones just
a linear function exponential
um uh and some others
and the qualitative results don't don't
depend on that
as long as it's a strictly decreasing
function um we get
qualitatively the same results and the
qualitative results are really what
we um we take to be trustworthy here or
in any way
you know the relevant output of the mod
okay so what are the results of this
well first
there's a new possibility now the new
possibility
is that for certain values
of this parameter m
which governs uh how
strongly
agents tend to distrust other agents
um we can begin to see polarization
so when that parameter
exceeds a certain value conventionally
set to one
uh in the model as we've set it up we
see polarization which are
stable outcomes where some agents have
high credence
that b is better and some have low
credence that b is better
i.e they believe that a is better and
moreover it's stable
because the agents don't trust one
another
they've come to occupy to um be distant
enough
from one another in belief space that
the agents that are performing action b
and um producing evidence that
the better action is in fact better uh
no longer influence the agents who
uh believe that age that action a is
better
right and so what happens is uh although
lots of evidence is being produced
and loss of evidence is being shared
you've gotten to a situation
where the agents are so distant from one
another that they don't trust one
another and they don't
update in light of the evidence that's
shared by
the other group and
um one way of thinking about what
happens here is as
m becomes larger and larger the
um the the distance in belief
but that needs to be achieved in order
for
this um or failure of listening
to occur gets smaller and smaller
and so the idea is that you know there's
there's some parameter here that's going
to govern how that works
um and so here's a chart that shows how
how that happens in the model
um as i said before m equals one is
conventionally set as the the value of
the parameter for which
uh it's even possible for them to stop
listening to one another as opposed to
merely
treating each other's evidences uh very
uncertain but still
updating on it and so as you see as m
gets larger various sizes of networks
what we see is that polarization
becomes increasingly likely um
and once m gets up to two or a little
bit higher
you begin to see polarization in all or
nearly all
runs okay
good just note that it's not just that
that um sort of this parameter m doesn't
just increase polarization it it also
increases
the uh the the total number of false
beliefs that are held by
a community and so what you see here are
plots of
average outcomes across a large range of
different
parameter values different values of n
different values of
the number of agents in the network
and so on different values of epsilon
how hard a problem it is how how big
is the difference in expectation value
between action a and action b
and what you see is across all those
different parameters as
m increases the
fraction of the network
that ends up holding false beliefs
increases um and so
you're going to see different fractions
depending on the different other
parameters but each of these lines is
higher than the one before
okay so there's lots more that i could
say about this model but the point is to
describe several models so
let me move on and just point to some of
the takeaways from this model
that are going to be important in the
discussion that follows
so i think the first takeaway is just
that polarization can apparently occur
under these sorts of circumstances that
is it can occur in an epistemic
community
with certain kinds of properties in
which agents tend to distrust
evidence produced by some agents where
that distrust is conditioned on
their difference in belief
now in the present model
uh the i the phenomenon is driven by the
fact that agents
explore i.e perform the action
that they think is better and so
it's the people who believe b is better
who are performing action b
who are generating data about action
being
and it's precisely those agents that
are ignored by or distrusted by the ones
who hold the false belief the one to
think that action a is better um
and so what's happening here is that
distrust is preventing the reliable
information from reaching the people
who would need it to
reach more reliable uh
beliefs and so you might think of this
as
possibly a way of modeling certain kinds
of
um certain kinds of uh
vaccine hesitancy where um
uh some people are believe that the
vaccines
you'll say a copy vaccine is safe and
effective other people think
um it hasn't been shown to be safe or
hasn't been shown to be effective
um there's a lot of data now population
level
data uh hundreds of millions of people
across the world who have received this
vaccine
good data on what their outcomes have
been so far
but if that data isn't trusted by the
people who
are skeptical for various reasons maybe
they think it's manipulated maybe they
think
that people are trying to mislead them
or have some ulterior motive
they're not going to update their
beliefs and light up that data even
though it's present
so um i just want to say once again uh
this is a particular model but in fact
this is consonant with a very
large literature discussing um
especially what's sometimes known as
opinion dynamics
uh in the case where um
agents condition how their beliefs
change on the distance between their
belief
or their opinion and that of other
agents
so this is a widely studied phenomenon
it's one
common possible explanation that you see
in
um the mathematical social sciences
literature for
how polarization might arise
okay now i'm going to switch gears we're
going to talk about another network
epistemology model
one that invokes a different mechanism
to explain
polarization which i'm going to call
conformity
once again this is uh based on a paper
that uh kalyn and i
wrote together uh
kayla doesn't like this paper as much so
she let me be first author on this one
okay so conformity so there's a very
long literature in social psychology
that um experimental literature that
documents
a tendency of human subjects to
conform with members of their social
group
um the ash experiments in particular is
one where
uh you have a subject um
in a group where the other groups are
are not experimental subjects but are
um uh members of the research team
and what happens is the uh the whole
group are shown
a number of pictures right so you have a
line and then two other lines with
um uh or two or three other lines anyway
you're showing a line you're showing
some other lines and you're asked
is this first line uh the same length as
one of these other ones
and um the various uh research group
participants i mean the ones who are
are not subjects uh say
that um something that's obviously false
that you know this line which is clearly
the the same length as this other line
is longer
and then the the research subject is uh
asked
to uh to to give their um opinion on
this
and you find that in a significant
number of
uh cases they will go along with the
group
despite the uh the fact that just
the evidence of their senses right the
fact that it's obviously the case
um that uh uh the group has
um the other members of the group have
expressed some
false view um okay so
uh given that tendency we might try to
introduce conformity
into a network epistemology framework
as follows so the idea here is that
when you're making a decision about what
action to perform
you might be thinking about the payoff
you'll get from performing that action
but you might also be considering some
other preferences that will enter into
an expected value calculation
and so um one such preference
might be a desire to
conform your actions to the actions of
your neighbors
so um we model this
by adding a conformity parameter which
tracks how
much payoff actors get simply from
matching their behaviors
to those of their network neighbors now
um we once again adopt a very low
rationality
model here we aren't um each agent
isn't trying to model the beliefs or
likely actions of the other
agents around them all they're doing is
they're saying well what did people do
in the last round
um if uh um most people
did action a then i'm going to expect to
get a payoff
from conforming to action a um and what
i
in order to choose to do action b i need
to not only believe that action b is
better
but i also need it to be the case that
um the benefits
that i i get by um you know the good
feeling i get
by conforming to all of my neighbors
doing action a
uh has to overcome the benefits of
performing action b
okay and so the idea here is that we're
going to weigh two different desires a
desire to
choose accurate actions and get the
payoffs that
come with that and a desire to conform
with neighbors
now when we introduce this
we once again like with uh the trust
dynamics
um begin to see new possible outcomes
for the model
so simulations can still approach either
true consensus or false consensus those
are still possible outcomes
but um another possible outcome that
doesn't exist in the base model
is a situation where uh the network may
can converge to a situation where
everyone performs the same action
even though some agents secretly believe
that the other action is better
but they don't perform the other action
um
because they prefer to convert to
conform
and because they don't perform the other
action no new evidence regarding the
superiority of the other action
uh is introduced into the network and so
although um there are uh
there's some diversity of belief here
it's not reflected
in the data that's generated and shared
in the network
um and uh uh
we we call that situation um we have two
different names one is true disagreement
and false disagreement so true
disagreement is a situation where
everyone's performing the better action
but there's disagreement still the other
situation is
where everyone's performing the worse
action they're performing action a
even though some people um believe that
action b is better
now finally we can uh find an outcome
where
you get polarization and action and
belief
so the idea here is that um under some
circumstances
specifically in the presence of certain
network structures
what can happen is that one group
comes to believe that action a is better
and they all perform action a
and another group comes to believe that
action b
is better and they'll perform action b
but the information doesn't pass
effectively between the groups so
to see how this depends on network
structure let me introduce a few
basic network structures so um consider
lots of different things
um the cycle the wheel the com
complete network these are standard
networks to consider we're not gonna
they're not that important for our
purposes the ones that are important for
our purposes or what happens when you
have a randomly generated network
using various different kinds of
algorithms for generating networks
or in particular you look at networks
that you might describe as clumpy
or having clicks so the idea here is
that
uh polarization is going to appear
specifically
in cases where
networks have a click structure so how
does this work
well the idea is if you have a click
here is defined
as a group of agents that are tightly
connected to one another
but only weakly connected to other
groups of agents who are in turn
mutually tightly connected to one
another as we see in this case we have
two separate complete networks that are
linked only by a single
edge and so the way in which
polarization can appear here
is that in one of these clicks
uh everyone comes to believe action b is
better
they perform action b um and they they
that sort of mini network uh approaches
a true consensus
whereas in the other click everyone
comes to perform action a
and almost all of them believe that
action a is better
but in fact the one agent in this
picture
who has access to the information from
the other click
will generally over time come to update
on that information come to believe that
in fact action b
is better but because of their
preference to conform
and there's only one action b doer in
their immediate network but there are
many action a
doers in their immediate network they
never switch their action
but because they're a kind of bridge for
this information
because they never switch their action
the other agents in their click
never receive data showing that action b
is better so the picture is one where
that that agent uh conforming
um sort of blocks the spread of reliable
information
into their click
and so you can see uh different kinds of
outcomes here depending on how strong
this conformity
parameter is basically the conformity
parameter is just a measure of how
how strong the preference is for
um conforming your actions to those of
your neighbors
what you see is that um
you know as conformity increases correct
consensus
still tends to be uh more likely
correct disagreement is the the next
most likely
outcome and then you start seeing these
uh incorrect
consensus and incorrect disagreements
but then you have this very
small likelihood here of getting
polarization
but that you know how big that
likelihood is depends on just what your
network structure is and so if we look
at specifically different network
structures
we see different results and so
um especially in the case of high
conformity which is the uh the plot on
the uh
the left here unless i'm mirrored in
which case it's the plot on the right
um the one that's labeled high
conformity
what you see is that in the clumpy case
right this case with the strong click
structure
uh nearly half of all outcomes are
polarized outcomes
um and so uh if you have a network that
has that structure
then you can expect polarization to
occur
simply due to conformity without needing
any other explanation
so what can we take away from this well
in the presence of certain network
structure
conformity provides another sufficient
cause for polarization
and that's because of this this
mechanism whereby you get bottlenecks as
i described
now if you're thinking well i mean how
realistic
are these sorts of uh clumpy networks
well the answer is that in fact um uh
research empirical research on um all
sorts of
real human social networks from the
structure of
uh facebook networks to studies of
sort of ordinary um offline populations
suggests that real social networks have
a characteristic known as
a small world property which means that
um uh agents tend
to uh have few connections but to have a
very short path length
between them and anyone else is
sometimes called the kevin bacon effect
where um uh jim is this
uh jim are these also referred to as
bubbles
or is that slightly different so that's
that's slightly different this this
this predates the idea of uh your filter
bubbles
um by uh decades
yeah so this is just a general result in
network theory that you can describe
small world networks and then it turns
out to be an empirical fact that you
have these sorts of small world networks
in
real real situations where and they're
called small worlds because
so the the small world metaphor isn't
supposed to be one where you think
we have these these isolated worlds that
are distinct from one another like
little
worlds rather it's the small world
phenomenon like who would have known
that you knew so and so um or that you
are just two or three connections away
from so-and-so
now i don't remember the number exactly
but it's something like uh on average
the average path length between random
facebook
um uh um
members is uh very very low it's like
four or five
um and so you know the average path
length for information to spread
to anywhere in the network uh is
surprisingly short
um but the point is that these small
world networks are ones that have clicks
um and if you um
there's a standard algorithm for
generating small world networks
generating random small world networks
known as the strogatz watts
algorithm if you use that algorithm to
generate your networks
using that random networks with this
conformity dynamics you find
polarization at a much higher rate than
in
the other sort of more uniform networks
that uh
i introduced
okay so this is another kind of possible
explanation for polarization having to
do
with uh the network structure of human
interaction
let me now introduce uh yet another
model with a totally different
framework and mechanism now this last
paper is a work in progress
um it's collaborative with kailyn but
also with uh
one of our graduate students uh aidan
mohsein
okay so the last two models considered
uh social factors um as you know the
ways in which
people update on evidence
from other agents and um uh
change their behavior in light of the
behavior of other agents uh to explain
how polarization can appear
um in this model we're going to to look
just at individuals
who are engaged in kind of a bayesian
learning
activity based on a stream of data
generated by some outside source
and we're going to understand this this
data generated by the outside source to
represent
information that they receive from some
media
so you can think about this as applying
to different kinds of cases you can
think about it as applying to
uh you know traditional news media
or you can think about as applying to
social media but the idea is that
there's some
some process by which the data that they
see is
generated by some intermediary the data
that they see is somehow curated
by some some something between them in
the world
um and the idea is that there's a
curation process that involves some
practice use right so some processes
involved in choosing
what data of all the data that's that's
sort of generated in the world
um agents actually update on what we're
going to ask is how
those practices interact with individual
reasoning biases to influence belief
so here's the basic picture
news media do not report on all events
in the domain
some events are selected for coverage so
how do you choose
which events to cover now
if you look at actual practice you look
at um
norms for how journalists should
practice you see various criteria
um described that um are applied
to select which of the events are going
to be reported on
right and so just as an example it's a
you know classic
adage of uh journalism you don't report
on dog bites man you report on man bites
dog right so you report on the things
that are unusual or unexpected or
perhaps extreme events
right the biggest hurricane you know the
worst hurricane season the you don't
report on every earthquake
you report on the ones that are above a
certain uh
threshold on the richter scale um
another example of a criterion that
might be applied
the long-standing norm in uh journalism
which in the u.s was actually
um part of a official fcc policy until
the 1980s
that um and joins journalists previously
required journalists
to report fairly now this idea of
fair reporting was given a particular
um characterization the idea was that
if you ever reported on some
controversial matter
you would need either within your story
or elsewhere within
your organization to also give equal
time
to other sides of that issue
and so even to this day usa today for
instance if they
run a an editorial on a controversial
topic they always pair it with an
editorial
supporting the opposite position but you
also see
within just regular articles
an expectation that the other side will
be described or will be given some
some space to express their views
okay so these are two different examples
of what i mean
by criteria that may be applied to
select which
events are reported so
how are we going to model this well
here's the idea the idea is that
um there's some
range of events that occur in the world
think of it maybe as storms
and the storms are sampled from some
normal distribution w right so you can
think of this the severity of the storm
as just being some
um something that that is randomly
generated um
sampled from some random variable
distributed according to this normal
distribution w
with fixed mean and fixed standard
deviation
now journalists aren't going to cover
every storm that happens what they're
going to do is they're going to
select from this initial distribution
which events to cover
and you can think of this as a process
by which the distribution w
is transformed into another distribution
which you could call a reported
distribution r
which generally differs from w
okay and so now we have some agents who
are interested in learning about how the
world
is but they're getting their information
from journalists and so what they're
doing is they're updating their beliefs
on data that's randomly sampled from
this new distribution are the
distribution
of reported events and what we're
interested in
is how does their posterior
distribution how does the the bayesian
agent's beliefs
about the world differ from the
distribution of actual events
in particular we're going to assume that
the underlying process
we can take the agents to assume that
the underlying process is gaussian
with unknown mean and variance they're
going to assume interchangeability and
what we're going to do is normal uh
model their beliefs with what's known as
a normal inverse gamma distribution
now the important thing here is just
that distribution
allows them to calculate an expected
value for
the mean of w and an expected value
for the standard deviation or the
variance of w
um and what's going to happen is we're
going to be able to compare those
expected values for the mean and the
variance with the actual mean and
variance of w
okay and so we're going to assume that w
is some normal distribution
it's got some fixed mean and variance um
the mean mu
in general can uh be off zero and so
we're gonna
assume that there's some social neutral
point sort of what you know
um uh uh what people take
um you know what journalists i should
say
take to be the uh um you know sort of
common knowledge about you know where
things are on average but the actual
distribution is going to be um
and maybe uh deviate from that
um and now we're going to consider a few
different processes by which the
reported distribution
r is constructed so one hyperbole
journalists just exaggerate so um
sometimes yeah so what happens is you
know x occurs
they report some factor h times x you
know it's
the biggest storm the worst hurricane
the biggest uh earthquake even if it
isn't really the biggest
um okay so we have some parameter h that
governs how that works
here's another process um extremity
journalists only report on events that
lie some distance
from the neutral point and so
um this is again like i'm not going to
report on every earthquake i'm only
going to
report on the ones that exceed some
value uh on the richter scale
um and then the final one is fair
reporting which i discussed before
and the way that we're going to model
that here is that every time you have an
event
that journalists want to report on on
one side of the neutral point
they need to look for another event that
represents the other side so every time
they
report on one side they report on the
other side as well
now they're always reporting real events
they're just pairing them in a way where
every event on one side corresponds to
event on the other
now we're also we also consider
distributions that result from combining
these we look at each of these
individually we combine them in various
ways
um now just to give you a sense of what
this does
each of these transformations can be
understood to produce
a distribution and so if we start with
our distribution w labeled here as the
objective distribution what hyperbole
does
is sort of flatten that distribution but
also shift its mean a little bit away
from the uh
um the neutral point zero um what
extremity bias does
is it just cuts out part of the events
so not all of the events are reported
just the the tales
um and then fair reporting uh
does this thing where you basically
take the part of the distribution uh on
each side
of the neutral point
and you normalize it so that
the probability of being on one side or
on the other is 0.5
right that corresponds to pairing these
events
um but you do it in such a way that
um you're only you're keeping the shape
of the distribution the same
you're just rescaling so that the total
area underneath the distribution to the
left of zero is equal to that to the
right of zero
so what sorts of results do we see here
well
an agent updating on data sampled from r
converges to a posterior distribution
that approximates r right so we're just
approximating each of these
distributions as a normal distribution
in general these are going to differ
from the true distribution
um you can that you know error with
respect to the mean or the variance
but um you're gonna be able to see these
as a pretty
um straightforward approximation of
the reported uh evidence
so what you see then is that well the
way you get the most reliable beliefs is
just by reporting on the true
distribution of evidence
so here's just an example of this sort
of
uh cognizant of time here i'm timing
myself i've been going for 52 minutes
but uh i started a little bit late and i
know that it's one now so i'm going to
pick up the pace a little bit here um
so uh here's an example of this
um you have some true distribution of
evidence you then have a reported
distribution of events
combining some of these different uh
distortions
and then you end up with some posterior
uh this is the one on the uh the pink
one here
some posterior distribution that
approximates with a normal distribution
the reported evidence
okay so
now let's consider the following
addition to this
model we suppose that instead of
updating on all of the data that
journalists produce
agents uh have a cognitive bias
they have a tendency to
prefer to update on data that
is consistent with their existing
beliefs
so this is known as confirmation bias
where individuals seek out evidence that
supports their existing beliefs they
ignore evidence that conflicts with them
or alternatively sometimes they
reinterpret evidence that conflicts with
their beliefs
as uh supporting their beliefs when they
when it doesn't
so here's how we're going to implement
this idea we're going to suppose that
there's some probability for any
reported event that the agent uh updates
on that event
um but that probability is going to be
less than one
and it's going to be a decreasing
function
of the distance between data and the
agent's expectation for the mean result
so one way of thinking about this is um
the probability
of updating on data that
the agent thinks is very likely is going
to be higher
than the probability of updating on data
that the agent thinks
is very unlikely
okay so what happens when we introduce
this modification
well it turns out that when with this uh
modification once again based on very
well documented psychological
behavior in real people we get a very
different kind of outcome
now what happens is instead of trying to
approximate
the uh whole distribution of reported
events with the gaussian
what we find is that agents tend to con
converge to
a gaussian centered at or near
one of the modes of the reported
distribution in particular whichever
mode
is closest to their prior expected me
so what this means is that for bimodal
reported distributions which can occur
when you have um extremity bias or when
you have
fair and balanced reporting um
you can come up with situations you find
situations where
uh agents that have priors on one side
converge to the mode closest to them
whereas asians that have beliefs on the
other side
converge to the node that's closest to
them
and these are going to generally be
different from one another and in fact
what you can see
is that over time beliefs can actually
diverge from one another
priors that are close to one another can
uh uh become more distant with more data
um and the reason that happens is even
though the mo the
the priors are initially close to one
another nonetheless one is closer to one
mode and the other closer to the other
mode
and they approach the modes of the
reported distribution
so here's a figure that shows that
happening you have some true
distribution of evidence
you have here some combination of
extremity bias and
fair reporting that leads to some
distorted um reported
distribution of evidence and what you
find is
in these these two different charts on
the right
the two pink ones um
agents that um begin with slightly
different priors
where you see that that in both cases
they're they're uh
their priors are know they're less
certain than they end up being the
priors the
the um more the less opaque
um gaussian what you see is that
although they start kind of close to one
another over time
they separate and moreover their
confidence becomes
a much greater i.e their expected value
for
the standard deviation of the events in
the world
becomes um smaller
and so neither agent ends up
approximating the true distribution of
events very well
um they both have smaller variants in
the true distribution of events and they
get the mean wrong
okay so this is the kind of polarization
right it's a polarization
where agents with different priors um
presented with the same evidence end up
with different posteriors um and what's
driving this result
is the way that we've modeled
confirmation bias along with the way in
which
the evidence is presented
what happens is in cases where there's
little or no data that
lies between the two modes agents don't
get pulled towards the true central
behavior
right so they never end up approximating
w
because all they ever see or all they
ever actually update on
is data that lies uh near one of the two
modes
now i think you know it's not really the
point of the talk today i just want to
flag though one very interesting result
of this work
is that hyperbole which i think is is
arguably the only of these biases that
we really consider
um problematic uh
generally speaking or at least
incompatible with good journalistic
practice
um actually doesn't contribute to
polarization
unless you also have fairness and
extremity bias um
and uh extremity bias especially to a
lesser extent now fairness
um do conform with journalistic norms
um i think that it's it's not considered
problematic
for journalists to report only on uh
things that are considered interesting
or novel or
out of the ordinary
okay so again in the interest of time
i'm going to do this
briefly but i'm going to ask now what do
these models taken together
tell us about the real world phenomenon
of polarization
which model is right now
i think that there's a a tempting line
of thought here
just to think about this sort of
situation in a way analogous to how you
might think about
a scientific theory so the idea here is
you come up with some model that model
reproduces some qualitative phenomenon
you might take that fact as primo fascia
evidence that some feature of the model
actually describes how you know some
aspect of how
say a social situation or social group
functions right this is a move that's
very similar to a standard inferential
pattern
often attributed to scientists whereby
if you have a theory
that makes some prediction say about the
outcomes of some experiment or
the tendency of some phenomenon to occur
and then you find that that phenomenon
occurs
you infer that the theory must be true
or approximately true or you increase
your credence that that particular
theory
is accurate um
now there's a well-known defeater for
this sort of reasoning
which is a situation in which you have
what sometimes called under
determination
of theory by evidence that is you have
many different theories that are
apparently
equally compatible with the observed
data so
in a case like that if you have
different theories that explain the data
and you don't have a way of choosing
between them you might say well
that means that undermines my my
confidence in any of them
so you might think that the right moral
to draw
from models of the sort that i've just
discussed is that look these models
can't tell us
anything about how real world
polarization
works we can't infer anything from them
they disagree about the underlying
mechanism they provide different
explanations
um and uh that means that we can't
choose between them
and if we can't choose between them that
means that we
can't for instance um use them to make
any kinds of policy recommendations
we can't use them to um think about
you know how we got into a particular
epistemic situation how we might get out
of it
we can't use them to to reason
effectively about the world as we find
it
and so you might think then this that
that really what we need
to understand real world polarization is
something something very different
so maybe some combination of
fine-grained empirical evidence
something that can can really
distinguish these cases from one another
help us understand what's really going
on
um now maybe there's still a role for
models of the sort or
perhaps actually successor models that
um
are um you know attempt to model the
world with greater
um detailed accuracy
um because then you might think well
what the models can do is come up with
more specific
and discriminating predictions that we
could then use
to distinguish between the possible
explanations of polarization
presented by each of these models
now i want to suggest that that is not
at all the right moral to draw from this
situation
but in fact we can draw much stronger um
and more important morals
from uh the the models as
presented and why is that well
the kind of dialectic i just presented
seems to take for granted that if these
models
disagree about the underlying cause of
polarization
then they are incompatible right and
this is the sort of thing you might
think to be true
if uh you're talking about say theories
in physics
where different theories
you know if you have two different
theories of the electron you might think
only one of them can be right
and so if both of them reproduce the
data you have you don't have a way of
choosing between them even though
you know only one of them could be
correct but that's not what's going on
here
it's not the case that these different
mechanisms are incompatible
rather i think what we see here
is that there are apparently multiple
sufficient causes
for the social phenomenon of
polarization now i
as i said at the beginning i don't at
all mean to suggest that what i've given
here
is an exhaustive list or even the most
important examples
of possible causes of polarization
i just claim that these are models that
suggest that
a certain kind of mechanism
may be sufficient for polarization
but all of these mechanisms can be
present together
right it can be that we have
confirmation bias in fact it appears we
do have confirmation bias
and it may be that we have conformity
bias and in fact it appears we do have
conformity bias
um and it may be that we tend to trust
some sources of evidence more than
others and perhaps
we condition based on the epistemic
success
of the uh the originator of the evidence
which apparently is something that we do
do
so all of these can be operative at the
same time now what that means is that
even if you had
more fine-grained empirical data
and predictions that tried to
distinguish between the different models
the fact that you could get good
evidence
that one of these mechanisms is present
and is leading to polarization
does not imply that the other ones are
not
also present and also contributing to
polarization
so in fact i think that the right way of
thinking about what's going on here
is that we see that evidence for
a particular hypothesis here about what
causes polarization
isn't evidence against other alternative
you might have thought competing but in
fact complementary
explanations of polarization and so
um i take that to uh
be the the basis for a strong cautionary
note
about how to think about policy making
um intended
to um uh
somehow ameliorate polarization
particularly say polarization and social
media
the idea is that policy interventions
tend to focus on unitary explanations of
a phenomenon
there's some positive cause some idea
that if you intervene on that cause
through policy making say changing the
way that algorithms can work on facebook
changing the way that that twitter works
number of twitter followers someone can
have
whatever um that by intervening on that
particular variable
you're going to have some
clear impact
or influence on the the
the thing that you're trying to change
in this case polarization
but if it's true that there are multiple
mutually compatible
independently sufficient possible causes
for polarization
it's not clear that any single
explanation is going to suffice
and that means that policy interventions
that target a single cause
are not only um unlikely to succeed on
their own
but may even backfire because what you
need to be attentive to is the way in
which
um by trying to block one mechanism
which is actually present you can
unwittingly amplify another mechanism
which is also present just as an example
suppose you're the sort of person that
thinks that conformity
and um just you know poor connections
between different networks of people
this is priya mentioned the filter
bubble idea but that's basically what's
going on
um on this sort of proposal the idea
would be well what's going on is that
you have
um you know people sometimes say a red
internet and a blue internet republicans
see some things when they go online
uh democrats see other things when they
go online they're updating on different
stuff
they're conforming with different groups
and it's by uh sort of separating
those that you end up with polarization
and so if we increased
the connections right showed more
democrats
more republican media and showed more
republicans more democratic media you
might think what's going to happen is
you're going to have some convergence
well it could be that conformity and
these network
effects are playing a role but
nonetheless trust dynamics is also
playing a role
in which case by exposing more exposing
people more to the other side
if they distrust the other side enough
it's either not going to make any
difference or may under some
circumstances even make
people tend to um polarize more
um for instance uh using something like
uh um well under some
some modifications of the trust dynamics
can actually lead them to
polarize more and so what this means
practically speaking is that empirical
work
cannot be directed only to positively
identifying
uh specific causal factors right not
only to showing
that some factor is operative in some
context
but also to establishing what other
factors
are also operative and to weighing the
relative
causal contribution of the possibly many
different
causal factors now this is a much more
difficult kind of activity
and something that i think it's very
it you know we don't have great methods
to my knowledge
of of establishing this kind of relative
uh uh amount of significance but it
seems to me that in
a situation like this where we have
multiple sufficient
causes for a social phenomenon
and some reason to think that all of
them may be present and may
be important this is what we need to
figure out
how to do in order to be able to
properly evaluate
any kind of policy proposal that's going
to be
successfully sensitive to the uh the
full complexity of the situation
thank you
thank you so much jim that was
absolutely fantastic
um and so i would like to
invite everyone to unmute and happiest
um yeah much to think about
so if i may before opening up the floor
to questions
uh ask you one myself
um i was just i mean i i really like
your caution
showing that there are many ways to
think about it but that we need to
really be
cautious about concluding that there's
one simple solution
or that we have captured the under you
know the actual
real-world polarization adequately
uh with any of these models uh to really
chase after one solution or the other
i think i wanted to come back to this
issue
that that you did raise in the beginning
and bring in the work of
dan kahan who is at the center for
cultural cognition at yale
where you know he's been studying as you
know the sort of disbelief in climate
change and
science denialism so it sounds like you
know this
this landscape of priors that people
have
that you know these are informed by
very but by our tribal identities
and they are part and parcel
of a larger worldview so one of the
things he his findings
often show that you know there are sort
of these two
broadish mindsets sort of a more
collectivist mindset and a more
individualist
mindset and that this mindset is
independent of one's position on
any one particular issue that is a broad
lens with which people see the whole
world and therefore then
every issue gets refracted through that
lens so i was very curious
um you know in these modeling approaches
you obviously have room for priors and
stuff but i was
curious what can if anything
be done about what seems like a
fundamental
psychological uh sociological schism
between personality types that is you
know very historically culturally
politically rooted
um and you know the same sort of
simplistic arguments have been about you
know east versus west collective versus
individual
etc so i was very curious how you would
see
that kind of you know broader view
of the world institutions people
etc uh being folded into thinking about
how it sort of manifests
in polarization um
so i think i have
maybe two things to say um
one is that um
i see it as a kind of yes and sort of
situation
where um i think
you know each of the kinds of mechanisms
that i pointed to there's there's
psychological evidence that that we
engage in in this sort of
behavior that we do differentially trust
sources that we do
prefer to conform um
there's psychological evidence to
support this idea
of um
background either ideologies or perhaps
even something more basic about how we
think about
the world right i mean i think sometimes
in this literature it's not totally
clear that you can distinguish a case
where it's culturally constructed and
ideological and people sort of subscribe
to a set of beliefs
and a case where people actually
self-sort based on
um the strength of their disgust
reaction i mean so you see papers
like this saying well you know um
conservatives tend to have a stronger
disgust reaction or tend to have
different kinds of reactions uh to fear
to outsiders
it's sort of it's hard to know um i
think at this stage
uh other people may know more but it's
hard for me to know
um at this stage uh whether we should
think of that as cultural
or innate across individuals um
but once again it's something that even
if that weren't there
other aspects of human psychology seem
to be sufficient to explain polarization
um and so if we focus all of our
attention on uh trying to
sort of solve this underlying
tribalistic
sort of tendency um i i think that we're
going to
to miss other things that are probably
also mattering right
that's one thing the second thing is
that um
i i have a kayla and i have another
paper together
where um we push back against some of
these ideas that
that the right way of explaining um
political tribalism is via some
organizing principle like
ideology which isn't exactly the same as
what you're describing but it's closely
related
um uh and so um george lachoff for
instance at berkeley has this idea that
there are two basic ideologies the
nurturing mother
and the strict father um and everyone
falls into one or the other so when you
disagree about gun control
you disagree about um you know coven you
aren't disagreeing about those things
you're disagreeing about whether
you you know the state should be a
nurturing mother or a strict father
um and we suggest that there are some
examples
where uh there appear to be correlations
between values or beliefs
that aren't really clearly explained by
this kind of
ideological explanation unless the
ideology becomes so
vague that really anything can be
associated with either of them well
but i guess but also you know there's a
tendency right especially in
western epistemology to be very
reductive and have like dichotomies
always break things into dichotomy so
it's like you know it's either this or
that and there's like
nothing sort of interpolating in between
so there's that problem
as well with that position as well as
what you are
uh suggesting is a so there's a deeper
problem
with those kinds of positions that are
very reductionist in some
way right reducing everything but so
what i would say though is i mean so
what we do in this paper is we
we show that actually you can uh arrive
at similar kinds of correlations between
beliefs
um with a kind of trust dynamics i see
where there's no organizing principle
it's entirely endogenous
and you get epistemic factions where you
have a whole bunch of different beliefs
totally unrelated beliefs but where
agents sort of clump
you know you've got all the ones who
believe action you know who prefer
actions a
a prime a double prime a triple prime
even they're totally unrelated
and then the ones that prefer b and b
prime and b double prime and so on
um without needing to introduce any kind
of
organizational principle um or
background ideology
or anything to sort of it just happens
via
a process where you know i agree with
you on gun control so i'm going to trust
your views about climate change and i
agree with you about that so i'm going
to trust your views about covet
and one example that we point to is um
and this is controversial but i really
like the example is uh
you know last march hydroxychloroquine
became the conservative treatment for
covid
and um uh remdesseviere became the
liberal treatment
for covid um at a
a point where there was far before there
was there was clear evidence
on it so you sort of you see this kind
of people sorting
into beliefs about matters of fact that
appear to depend on
their background you know other
background views but in a way i i don't
see any meaningful sense in which hydro
hydroxychloroquine is the strict father
solution to covet and
remdessevier is the nurturing mother
solution dekovid
or the collectivist versus
anti-collectivist one it seems like this
is just
something random happened but they
sorted
um so we have um
let me see um you can hear me right okay
so we have a question
uh from shinjeev kumar on the chat uh do
you think polarization per se
may not be problematic but the fact that
we have not developed a framework that
can rationalize
a pursuit for an underlying unity of
things
we don't say that our legs are polarized
so um there are two
two separate sorts of issues here one is
whether or not polarization is by itself
problematic
um and i think there are good reasons to
think that polarization is not
by itself problematic um
especially if polarization is in in some
way
transient right so i think there are
very good reasons to think
that um one reason why you might have
um mechanisms that slow down
learning and maybe preserve
transient polarization is because
it can take a long time to get reliable
consistent representative data
about the world and you know
a situation where you have for instance
different cultural groups or even
different individuals performing
different practices
and learning from those practices is one
perhaps where you can expect to achieve
better overall outcomes over time um
and so you might think that that some of
the mechanisms that lead to polarization
are actually mechanisms that over the
very long run
benefit social learning or benefit
cultural evolution or something like
that
it may even have been um uh
you know in some sense selected for um
so i i don't think polarization by
itself is necessarily uh
problematic the idea though that um
some of these you know really quite
dichotomous
situations like these these propositions
where there's a lot of evidence
um and yet nonetheless there seems to be
a very long
uh and apparently quite damaging
disagreement um i i i don't want to
think
i i'm not i'm not i don't tend to think
that that the right way of thinking
about such situations is one where
um uh there really are just two ways of
being in the world and they're equally
right
or you know in a way suggested by this
um
uh idea that our legs are are not
polarized
our legs are chiral i mean i guess
that's a different
physics
um any other questions please feel free
to
type them into the chat
well at any rate i have another question
so i will
again take the liberty uh jim to ask you
so um
i i wondered um whether
you found that for
particular issues some
models were better descriptors
i'm not talking about the solutions
because i mean i think i totally take
your point that
you know it would be just too simplistic
to just say that okay let's this is the
model
and therefore these are all the
solutions that can describe how to
mitigate the polarization
but i was curious so for example if you
took um sort of the polarization on the
issue of vaccination
for example um
versus climate change um
did you did you find in the modeling
approach
that you know one set of models
was like a better descriptor of the
problem because i think that's the point
that you're trying to make
that it's very hard to figure out and
restrict ourselves to one
unique model but i wondered
if there were particular kites you know
i'm just trying to see if there are ways
to map
particular issues to particular kinds of
agent models
um and whether you found that
uh whether there's something there that
you found interesting
for you know for matters that have to do
with you know personal being you know
like a medical issue which has to do
with our personhood
much more immediate salience than
climate change
which for many people feels like it's
quite distant because they are not
accepting that it has touched us in our
lives already right so
i was just curious about like the
proximity and you know what are the
other kinds of um
um beliefs whether the beliefs can be
classified in some way
in terms of a particular model being a
better descriptor
um so uh
to an extent i mean i want to emphasize
again that i mean
the models here are um
are so simple uh that
i'm reluctant to confidently assert that
what's going on any of these models is
um what's going on in any particular
real world case
um that said uh
i do think that some of the qualitative
features of the models
do seem to invoke particular cases
particularly well
and so for instance one of the things
that happens in the
the conformity model is that you have a
trade-off between how much you care
about successful action
and how much you care about conformity
um now
normally when we present the model we
think about it in terms of the strength
of your preference that can form
but another sort of dual way of thinking
about it is
the weakness of the benefits of
performing the successful action
and so there are some sorts of cases
where although there is a matter of fact
and there is a lot of evidence available
nonetheless as an individual the
decisions you make
uh um aren't going to have particularly
strong effects one way or the other
um even you know there's polarization in
the u.s
regarding uh evolutionary theory
um again it's the case where there's an
enormous amount of evidence available
but there's absolutely nothing that hurt
like
there's no way in which you're
individually hurt uh going around and
doing things
as an individual that that uh are
incompatible with evolutionary theory
which for most people just means saying
i don't believe in evolutionary theory
right that doesn't harm you in some way
but you do get the benefits perhaps of
conforming within your community
um climate change is a bit like that
because the consequences of your action
tend to be
remote in space and time right um
but other things like um you know
it it's harder to see
um some of the behaviors we've seen
around covet
as uh an example
of um that kind of behavior
on the other hand i mean kayla and i
actually considered
we didn't do it we considered writing a
um
an op-ed describing how covid like
perhaps reflected just a complete
failure of classical decision theory
where
you you think that you can
um you know that that people are
motivated right
by immediate benefits for harms
right and so sort of directly seeing
this kind of behavior let's these kinds
of outcomes for these kinds of people
who are close to me i see it directly
that that would affect your behavior
but that in fact it seems like other
sorts of considerations
um could counterbalance that kind of
direct immediate evidence
right especially now right i mean maybe
last march or april or may
you know you're not in new york you're
not in uh
um paris you know um
maybe you you don't trust the what
you're what you're hearing about
um but uh by now i think
people have much more direct experience
and yet many people still
are are act as if they're very skeptical
so um we have a question uh from jenny
wagner
is the timing of the update of
information
for each agent a critical issue imagine
you update
information of the agents asynchronously
would that change the behavior of the
entire network
so there are a few different kinds of
effects here um one has to do with how
often uh agents perform their action
before sharing evidence right so you can
think about this as
how large a sample do you collect before
stopping and updating your beliefs right
because um
when that's large uh you know you're
going to go with what you originally
think is the better action you're going
to gather a lot of data and then you're
going to reconsider
and you can think of that as a kind of
asynchronous updating because you aren't
updating every time you gather evidence
you're updating only
after a certain amount of evidence has
been gathered by each agent
and that absolutely changes uh
the um various things in in the models
it doesn't change the the qualitative
effects of these are the kinds of
outcomes and sometimes you get this and
sometimes you get that
but it does change things like the rate
at which agents learn
um which outcomes are more likely things
like that
um other kinds of asynchronous uh
learning might involve things like only
sharing every so often even though
you're updating more often
or some agents share and other agents
don't
one thing that we look at is a situation
where
only some agents are able to gather
information and so some agents are
updating only on evidence gathered by
others
we treat that as a situation where say
you have some policy makers we have some
scientists the policymakers are updating
on the scientists evidence
and uh all of those sorts of things can
can have a
an effect um but they uh
i think at the level of description that
i've i've given here they don't matter
to any of the results that i've reported
great um so there's uh one other
question from tyler lutz
who is a former frankie fellow
polarization might also be socially
advantageous in situations
in which truth itself for instance the
relative success of a versus b
changes with time do you have a sense of
how your models behave in such dynamic
circumstances
i have in mind here climate change in
particular in which most of us believe
that true distribution of climatic
phenomena is changing right before our
eyes
um so
uh i think that the answer
so we haven't looked at situations where
the actual um
uh uh success rates change i mean it's
an interesting modification to the
the model um but one that we haven't
looked at
um kevin zulman though one of his
earliest papers on network epistemology
uh really emphasized the importance
of what he called transient diversity of
beliefs but you might think also
as transient polarization um you know
and i mentioned this in response to
priya's comment early on oh no no to a
an earlier question
the idea that under some circumstances
uh polarization may actually be
beneficial
and so kevin's suggestion there is that
um uh basically
if instead of thinking of the um
a situation where the actual outcomes
uh change if you think about a situation
where over time you you get access to
new or different kinds of evidence um
having people who continue to hold the
thing that seems incompatible with the
old evidence
um means that they'll sort of pursue new
lines of evidence
and an example that he gives is the
discovery of the bacterial origins of
ulcers and so it turns out that there's
a bacterium called h pylori
that causes ulcers um
19 but you know by the 1960s this the
idea of a bacterial cause of ulcers was
basically uh um
ruled out by a series of
really a small number of very
influential experiments that claimed to
have shown that
the stomach is um
uh antibacterial basically that there
aren't bacterial cultures in the stomach
and so you can't have a bacterial cause
of ulcers
um and you know one of the the
you know people stopped pursuing that
line of research except in australia
where they were just disconnected enough
from the rest of the research community
they had their own
sort of autonomous research program
going and they continue to explore this
possibility and eventually identify the
kind of bacterium that hadn't
been known before um
and uh you know we're able to establish
that in fact that is present in stomachs
and in fact it does cause
uh um uh ulcers you know the guy who
literally i was gonna say this is a
famous case where the experimenter
actually took it right and yeah yeah he
drank the age glory
he then took an antibiotic so he gave
himself an ulcer by drinking the hblurry
and then cured it with an antibiotic and
it's not clear what the epistemic value
of that is but it's certainly
i think desperation science right to
persuade yeah
um so i i guess if there are no further
questions um i would really like to
thank uh jim for an excellent
thought-provoking talk
and we really look forward to the
discussion tomorrow
uh with professor viral and kevin dorse
so at this point
i just want to invite everyone to unmute
and um a clap if possible yeah
okay thank you priya so much yeah thank
you so much yeah look forward to seeing
you tomorrow
yeah see you see you all tomorrow again
at 3 p.m
thank you and actually uh before i
close um i realized i'd wanted to do
this at the beginning
uh today is the first anniversary of
george floyd's
death so um i just wanted us to
remember that in closing